hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the anxious rapid
Knockouts this comes after the
preliminaries uh 181 player uh fought
for the uh privilege to enter the top
eight and uh to fight for uh promotion
this is currently division two and the
winner of division two uh or the top
four will be upgraded to division one
and it's in Magnus cross and dropped out
of division one uh now he really wants
to re-enter and out of those 181 players
uh those who qualified for the Knockouts
are these gentlemen here so levonne
Magnus it's
all and the funny uh um funny thing
about this tournament is that the top
four get to choose who they who they
fight
um uh in the in The Knockout so Levon uh
chose gatakomski and then Magnus was it
was his uh turn to choose and he chose
Ivan sharitch and it's no wonder that he
chosenic is one of the few players in
the world that has a uh positive score
against Magnus carlsening classical
chess he defeated him uh he defeated him
in one game they played in 2014 and in
2015 in tata steel they drew their game
so of course Magnus would uh Magnus
takes up every opportunity he can where
he gets the play against Evan so let's
see what happened in this game uh they
play two games and then of course you
you uh go into the next round it's rap
it's 10 minutes per player plus two
seconds increment starting from move one
uh let's check it out so Magnus has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 and
that uh 99 of the time means that shot
will go for the Sicilian Defense he's a
very
aggressive player upon to C5 Knight to
F3 D6 and now Bishop the B5 check Magnus
tries the canal attack we have Knight to
D7 Ponte A4 and now Knight to F6 with
Knight to C3 and the G6 preparing to
finchetto the dark Square Bishop Ponte
A5 Magnus grabs more space on the queen
side and now Bishop to G7 with castles
by both players uh castles castles and
now Rook to E1 uh point a six challenges
the bishop and Magnus just uh brings it
back all the way to F1 Pawn to B5 and a
captures on B6 Alpha Song and now this
has all been as seen before you could
also just recapture here but charity
develops the bishop First bishop to B7
and now D3 and Rook to A3 are known
moves the Magnus plays Rook to A2 and it
is now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game and the idea behind
it being that of course you want to play
uh B3 Bishop to B2 your Bishop will be
guarded on B2 by the rook and at some
point you want to move the queen and
double up on the a file maybe put
pressure on the uh on Black's a pawn so
those are all General ideas so Queen
captures on B2 and B6 with quanta B3 and
now Knights the G4 opening up the dark
Square Bishop but not a problem H3
Knight to E5 and now Knight the D5
grabbing more space here Knight captures
on F3 Queen captures and queen back to
d8 regarding the E7 Pawn uh Bishop to B2
offering a trade of Bishops and now shot
is just trades Bishop captures Rook
captures and now Pawn to A5 Magnus just
brings The Rook back Rook to A2 that was
the idea for this Rook all along now
this Rook can come to A2 you can double
up here uh Pawn to E6 chases away the
Knight and knights the C3 and now
Knights the E5 an excellent Square for
shot each night uh Queen to G3 and now
Knight to C6 we're maneuvering all the
way to D4 could be an even uh better
Square Knight the B5 stopping Knight the
the Knight to D4 and now Pawn to E5 with
Bishop to C4 now uh pinning the the df7
pawn and now Knight to D4 offering a
trade and Magnus can't really allow this
Knight to remain here though it's also
putting pressure on the C2 Pawn so
Magnus just captures nine captures on
d4c captures and pawn to D3 now we have
King date getting off of this diagonal
so charge can execute F5 and just Rook e
to A1 for the moment charge is defending
the A5 Pawn but that also means his rook
and Queen have to remain there Ponte F5
as planned and now that pawn to F3 we
have captures an E4 D captures on e4 and
now Bishop to C6 with Queen to E1 now
tripling up the attack against that A5
pawn and now Queen to G5
gives up the pawn and shifts his
attention to the king side he wants to
attack now uh the white king it's not
gonna be easy to do this because you you
cannot Advance any of the pawns and well
uh you're just gonna be down a pawn so
Pawn to H4 Magnus throws in this move
maybe an unnecessary one you could also
just start capturing an A5 but okay
Magnus throws it in Pawn to H4 Queen to
F4 and now Rook captures on A5 we have
Rook captures Rook captures and now Pawn
to G5 if anything this move uh helps
Charlie to open up the king side a
little bit age captures Queen captures
and now Rook to A6 and here Magnus is
the the one pushing for a win here he's
up a pawn and he has five minutes on the
clock shot he chose a minute and a half
so he has to be very careful we have
rooked the C8 and now Magnus plays this
super tricky move Rook to B6 the idea
behind it is that you want to attack The
Rook uh of course The Rook has to remain
on the C file because the bishop would
hang so but the idea is Bishop to E6
rooked C7 then you deliver a check Rook
to beat with check King to G7 and of
course Rook to G7 with check as the
bishop also controls that square so you
give a check and then you pick up the
queen on G5 so that's the idea so shot
each has to figure out a way out of this
he finds it pawn to H5 this gives up
frees up the H7 Square for the black
king so after that uh check is given he
can just play King to H7 instead of
going to the G file and now uh it also
prevents this because now if Bishop to
E6 look at this bishop to D7 can be
played this is what shot is found in
this time scramble uh point is that you
cannot capture if you capture The Rook
captures on C2 and how you you defend
Checkmate you have to defend with the
queen and after Queen F1 Rook C1 just
wins the White Queen so uh not the best
so instead King the H2 Magnus spots this
at the end of the line that his King
should not be on the back Rank and now
charity advances the pawn further Pawn
to H4 now uh the queen will have some
very nasty checks here uh Bishop D6 by
Magnus and now we have Rook to C7 and
this Rook to C7 uh is uh well a
sub-optimal move to say the least the
way to play this is spawn to D3 it's a
very tricky move but the point is that
if you capture The Rook then you advance
the pawn all the way to D2 and after
Queen to G1 now you play Queen to G3
check and after King to H1 now you play
Queen to E1 and okay you will uh win the
queen of course you will have to give up
the bishop Queen captures King captures
and now D1 Queen uh you will have a
queen against a rook and Bishop with the
precise play this should be a draw but
basically what you have to do after D3
is not capture The Rook you play C
captures on D3 and again Bishop to D7
and okay now you can capture it but then
after captures Rook to C2 and again you
will have a queen for for two pieces the
queen still has to defend or you play
Bishop to G4 then just Rook to C1 uh it
will again be very problematic if King
to F2 Queen to F4 with the check now you
have to play G3 H captures and G3 with
check Queen captures and now Rook to
each one with checking G2 Rook G2 check
Rook to G1 check King will move or
capture of course then Queen captures
and G3 would check and now again a queen
against a bishop and The Rook with those
pawns uh fairly nicely defended uh
should yield nothing more than a draw
but charge played Rook to C7 and now we
have the king to H3 by Magnus White King
to H3 you're probably asking yourselves
well because it worked to be checked
right away King H7 and The Rook to G8
isn't all that impressive there's Queen
to F4 with check and you know nothing
nothing there so King to H3 avoids any
incoming checks and now Queen back to d8
guarding against Rook to B8 check Bishop
to F5 and now Bishop to D7 charge offers
a trade of Bishops but now Queen
captures an H4 with check there wasn't
really a way to avoid this with Queen
captures and H4 King captures Bishop
captures and f5e captures and The Rook
captures on C2 but now Pawn to G4 shares
plays Rook to C3 but Magnus just
advances his king a king to G5 and now
there's really nothing for you to do
here if you go back to try and defend
against Checkmate then Magnus just
collects here and you have no control
play you cannot push its um game over
social split Rook captures on F3 but he
was also very low on time and also in a
lost position so uh you know he had to
play something Magnus just played King
to G6 and he was in this position on
move 44 that even charge resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so very nicely done the thread of
course rooked to be to check this is uh
yeah you cannot defend against this you
could play some silly moves like Rook C3
Rook B8 check and then Rook to see it
but that would only prolong the game uh
or or rather the suffering for for three
more moves uh so yeah very nicely done
by Magnus not just um uh doing well in
the preliminaries but also winning the
first game of the Knockouts we'll see
what happens in game two against even
and if you guys have any of your games
uh of your favorite games from uh The
Knockouts or the preliminaries as there
have been you know uh 181 games have
been played uh 181 players have been
playing it that's 362 games if you have
any of your favorite games do use
hashtag suggestion I will check it out
and if it's a nice game we're gonna show
it uh most likely tomorrow uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it uh not too many variations but it is
rapid chess we don't want to go too
crazy so so I hope you don't mind that I
would like to thank Ricky Johnson father
Derek King Alexandria drola and Dean
bodenham for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing with uh the
coverage of ancientious rapid and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day